the US now has the most reported bovid
19 cases of any country in the world
this is like having a hurricane hit
every single city across the United
States all at the exact same time to
find out what it's like the health care
workers on the ground and to learn more
about the hospitalization timeline of a
patient with Kovac 19 I called up dr.
Cedric dark he's an ER physician in
Houston Texas so there you have a
waiting room full of people in the ER
who think who have fever
how does triage work in the ER from the
beginning of this we have literally
separated anybody with cough and fever
from everybody else in the hospital
other hospitals have tents set up
outside to screen people initially it
was we're gonna ask have you been to any
of the countries where where it's
present have you been around somebody
that's known to be diagnosed and are you
having a fever
if you screened in for any of those
you're definitely thrown into this
separate area then symptoms are you
feeling short of breath are you having
coffee if you have any of those issues
going on you're put in this special area
where we can screen you where we can
keep that part of the ER and the
providers there give them the maximum
amount of personal protective equipment
keep them safe and then also keep
everybody else in the ER safe because
still we're gonna get heart attacks
we're gonna get strokes we're gonna get
people that have been in car wrecks and
we need to keep those folks safe from
catching communicable disease as well if
I see somebody that does have a fever or
that does have some abnormal sounds when
I listen to their lungs that person I
think warrants getting a chest x-ray as
the disease progresses there are these
things called infiltrates or little
white spots that form in the lungs when
you look microscopically inside the
lungs think of it as like little bits of
fluid or costs or something they
sits inside the lungs which normally are
like a nice little sponge and that makes
the exchange of oxygen with the air
harder to happen and so therefore that's
why people start feeling short of breath
talk us through a bit about what the
chest x-rays are look like ask somebody
maybe first has Cove in nineteen and
then as they get sicker and sicker that
one that you're looking at right there
that x-ray looks fairly decent I don't
see a ton of haziness or white spots
what about this x-ray yeah that was bad
not only can I see on the x-ray that the
person is ventilated they have a
breathing tube in there in their trachea
or their windpipe you see a lot of these
little patchy spots like the little
white spots all over the lungs and it's
on both sides of the lungs so that you
know tells you that all that nice air
filled sponge sponginess of the lung has
been filled in with fluid and gunk in
this particular person is probably so
bad that they couldn't be maintained
just with like oxygen through the nose
that they had to put in a breathing tube
to give them additional oxygen how would
you treat this patient let's say a
patient comes in the short of breath
they get this x-ray at this point in
time I know I'm going to be admitting
them to the hospital and that person
essentially is what the CDC would call a
person under investigation
and so that's the patient that would get
tested once that decision is made to
hospitalize them and so we would do the
test right now the tests are taking a
long time to come back the testing at
this point is not for therapeutic
purposes it's more for epidemiological
purposes what help and support can you
give cope it 19 patients this is where
it gets a little tricky because there's
no defined treatment specific for Kovan
19 what we need to do is what we call
symptomatic treatment what that means is
if someone needs oxygen we give them
oxygen they have fever we might give
them medicines to reduce their fever but
other than that we kind of have to wait
for the virus to take its course if
someone goes into what we call
respiratory failure where their lungs
can't pull in enough oxygen that's when
we have to put them on a ventilator
machine and so we we do that procedure
where we put the
through the windpipe so all of those
patients have to be put into a medically
induced coma they stay on the ventilator
machine for the duration until they
improve and get better it can come off
as the disease progresses if it gets
worse those little white spots you saw
in the lungs could consolidate even more
and more into a condition called a RDS
what that means is the lungs become
completely useless and it's almost
impossible to deliver enough oxygen to
keep them alive at which point you know
someone could eventually succumb from
the disease when would you take someone
off a ventilator if someone gets really
sick and they've been on that ventilator
maybe for a few days hopefully the
inflammatory response or the virus
affecting the lungs starts to resolve
and their lungs clear up and they can be
taken off the ventilator and go back to
living a normal life what point are you
thinking about rationing ventilators and
who would get one and who wouldn't those
decisions are happening right now
and doctors are thinking about that and
I'm fortunate to not have to think about
that at the moment but it may become a
real thing if people don't take this
seriously enough what all hospitals in
the Houston area doing to get ready for
a potential surge of patients so one of
the things that they've been doing is
we've been canceling elective surgeries
so that we have fewer people in the
hospital in the first place
the other thing that we've been doing in
hospitals not only in Houston but across
the country has been trying to figure
out ways that we can use one ventilator
machine for more than one patient not
only are we dealing with a deadly
disease but we're also dealing with the
inadequate resources to protect
ourselves from that disease we have
supply chains that potentially could be
disrupted we've seen people kind of
hoarding things are ranging from toilet
paper to in 95 masks even when they
don't necessarily need it we've had to
conserve resources by reusing stuff that
should only be used once and instead
using it all day as long as it isn't
soiled the PPE that we need for every
confirmed patient to be absolutely safe
would be a gown
of facemasks either surgical mascar in
95 and eye protection with like a face
shield or goggles in terms of what most
hospitals are experiencing shortages of
its the masks sometimes the face shields
that's what we're typically having to
reuse on shift is this a situation you
ever anticipated being a doctor in
America never I mean we think of the US
as one of the most well resourced places
in the world when it comes to health
care
but it just goes to show that when when
there's sort of widespread panic
normal supplies can be depleted fairly
quickly and how do you mentally prepare
for what might happen and what's
happening right now not much is
different from what we're used to doing
every day in an emergency department
we're used to taking care of sick people
we are notoriously the people that think
about the worst case scenario of the
medicine world we are probably the
Doomsday Preppers but the thing where
we're not prepared for is making the
ethical decision of once we reach our
saturation point who do I decide lives
and who do I decided dies that we're not
ready for we don't know how big this
surge is going to be when it hits right
if it's small and we can weather that
storm great but if it is long and
sustained then it might completely flood
and overwhelm the system and with it it
will impact the health of the people on
the front lines and you have a kid at
home so how are you managing that coming
home from the ER and being a home it's
pretty difficult I think the one thing
that seems a little bit reassuring is
that at least children seem to fare
better at this than adults or especially
older adults my message for the public
three things number one stay home save
lives
we need to flatten the curve on this
number two please do not come to the
emergency room expecting it at a kovat
test if you're well enough to stay home
stay at home because we're not going to
be testing you anyway
and number three if you happen to have
any of that personal protective
equipment that we could use in the
hospital consider donating it to your
local facility or to the doctor that
might live down the street from you
really grateful for your time and thing
- so much for explaining this situation
to us no problem
Thanks